the war in ukraine is also inspiring
widespread protests inside russia itself
and observers say more than 5 000
demonstrators have been arrested there
long lines at russian banks at the same
time are just one of the many signs the
russian economy is plummeting under the
pressure of widening sanctions from the
west reporter mary illusina is in moscow
for us mary good morning to you
how are people feeling on the streets of
moscow as they watch things unfold in
ukraine
good morning
people here are definitely unnerved you
know they're worried that their usual
way of life is ending and it might end
very very soon they're worried that they
might not able to get out of the country
or even buy some foreign products so
each time this new headline comes up
with new country sanctioning russia a
lot of them are asking is it all worth
it
i'm curious to know how russians are
able to
get information about what's happening
in ukraine i know there is
disinformation there is an attempt to
censor what's coming into the country
and and then also uh when russians do
take to the streets what happens to them
yeah that's a very good point about
coverage because russian state tv has
not been showing russian forces
attacking kiev or attacking harkev for
them
the way they portrayed it's still a
special operation in donbass so russians
who watch tv don't really see all the
things that are going on in ukraine so
their only real way to find out what's
happening is social media but the
internet regulator here has been taking
steps to slow down twitter slow down
facebook and as you mentioned because of
the protests as well it's becoming
increasingly hard to speak out so it's
increasingly hard for russians who many
of them are against this war to say that
they are
yeah it's said that there's nothing that
vladimir putin fears more than democracy
free speech a part of that and as a
there's a crackdown on those who have
taken to the streets five thousand
demonstrators detained so far mary
ilicina in moscow us mary thank you very
much
thank you